known for her foul mouth and fiery
attitude Lily was one of modern family's
most memorable characters from food
reviews to viral Dance videos the
actress who played her has stayed very
busy since the show ended in the first
episode of Modern Family Cam Tucker and
Mitch Pritchard adopt a daughter named
Lily she's one at that time and in
typical Hollywood fashion portrayed by
baby siblings named Ella and Jaden
Hiller your daddies are being
ridiculous mommy then starting in season
3 an actor named Aubrey Anderson Emmons
took over the role Anderson Emmons was 4
years old when she joined Modern Family
meaning she was genuinely just about the
same age as Lily from that point on
Anderson Emmons remained a core member
of the Modern Family cast her one
additional acting credit meanwhile was
in a short film titled distance that
premiered in 2014 since the end of
Modern Family in 2020 Anderson Emmons
has yet to work in any other film or TV
but fans of her character can rest
assured that she's keeping plenty busy
as a content creator and artist while
Aubrey may not have landed more than a
single additional acting role outside of
Modern Family she made promotional
appearances as herself and occasionally
worked on reality TV throughout her time
on the sitcom in fact she earned her
second ever Credit in 2012 Aubrey made a
cameo in the Disney parks Christmas
parade special that aired on ABC
Aubrey's first talk show appearance came
one year later when she was part of a
Modern Family Feud segment on a Jimmy
Kimmel Live episode in 2013 then in 2016
she ventured outside of strictly
promotional work for the first time by
appearing as a celebrity judge on an
episode of Beat Bobby fle her busiest
year as a TV performer was 2018 in which
he was a contestant on the game show
Paradise run as well as a guest on both
home and family and the real her most
recent TV appearance was technically
after the last Modern Family episode
though it wasn't the A Farewell special
that aired in its immediate wake in
addition to her acting Anderson Emmons
has also done a considerable amount of
charity work when she was 11 years old
she began dedicating her time to an
impressive number of Charities including
St judee's hospital she's also done
charity work for the juvenile diabetes
research foundation and the Dave Thomas
foundation for adoption among others the
best way for fans of Anderson emmans to
keep up with her present day activities
is through her social media channels
like a typical Aubrey is most active on
Instagram and Tik Tok where she posts
regularly in fact one of her social
media videos even went viral in 2021
Anderson Emmons posted an otherwise
standard Tik Tok dance video which
amassed nearly 2 million likes the video
also received tens of thousands of
comments from users who were surprised
to see the former Modern Family
youngster all grown up I've changed
since Anderson Emon started acting when
she was just 4 years old her mother Amy
has been a key contributor to her career
from the very start in fact her mom is
an actor herself having appeared on
shows like Silicon Valley together
Aubrey and her mom review food on social
media under the name food Mania review
the project dates all the way back to
June 2015 meaning auy was just eight at
the time they continued posting
regularly on YouTube through November
2021 while that YouTube account is now
inactive Aubrey and her mom continue to
post to a food Mania review Instagram
page to this day Anderson Emmons May no
longer could be an active Hollywood
actor but she does perform as a musician
with some regularity her interest in
Singing in fact dates back to 2012 when
she was just 5 years old at that point
in Aubrey's life her mother shared a
video of her daughter singing the Adele
single Someone Like You the clip went
viral thanks in part to Aubrey's
Newfound Fame at the time nowadays
Anderson emons herself posts videos of
herself performing her own original
music to her Instagram and Tik Tok
accounts she also lends her talent to a
band called octob U which is based in
Los Angeles that said music seems to
have become Aubrey's primary mode of
artistic expression now that Modern
Family is firmly in her
[Music]
past